Bà khoảng không dở 3 mi phút hôm nay, 2 mi đàn tháng 1 năm, 2 mi khu trăm 2 mi sấu.
Chênh đến đường vóng mình giáp phường đồng hối tình quần sị,
người dân phát hiện bàn người đã từ vong, 2 người khác bị thương đợi đi cấp cứu.
Tong tình bàn đầu, thưa điểm trên có một nhóm thình nhân ở sả bắt chạch,
tình quần sị và phường đồng hối để chơi.
Sao đó, dụ thế một số người, ngôn mi một người,
đi năm xe một tồ trên đường vóng mình giáp,
khi đến địa điểm thuộc tổ dân phố hạn dương,
khá lời tượng đường khi phương tình trạch ở và trạm với nhau dẫn đến tên á.
Hầu qua, bán người từ vong tại hiện chương,
quần, hát đe tèa, sinh năm hành hủ trò lình tám,
chú phần đồng thuật, ngờ một tế, ngờ gờ bê,
cùng sinh năm hành hủ trăm bười, cùng chú sả bắt chạch,
2 người bị thương được cấp cứu, quần, lời đe tế,
sinh năm hành hủ trò lình chỉ,
và lợi a tế, sinh năm hành hủ trò lình một cùng chú sả bắt chạch.
Ngay sau phía vụ tên hạn xe ra,
đe dự lãnh đạo con hăng tình còn chỉ cùng cán bộ,
chỉ có phòng người vụ lình còn đã có mặt tại hiện chương
tổ chức xảy quyết buộc việc theo quy định của pháp lần.